des fûts à perte de vue nous sommes à la
money a rivière pilote est le maître des
lieux c'est lui daniel baudin 20 ans
déjà qu'elle exerce son art c'est le
maître de chai du groupe bbs belloni
bourdillon y successeur est déjà elle
prépare la relève avec son assistant le
nail bar elle s'est très végétal
donc il n'a pas encore pris les notes de
boisés le groupe a reçu six médailles
d'or pour ses hommes lors du salon de
l'agriculture des récompenses qui
viennent saluer le travail de daniel
bodart en véritable chimiste c'est lui
qui détermine tout le processus
d'assemblage de création et de
production
maître de chai c'est comme maître
d'école donc il a à élever des enfants à
éduquer des enfants donc le maître de
chai va éduquer ces roms en faisant le
choix de son fût de ces fut le choix de
son de ça chauffe et de ces assemblages
donc c'est comme comme un professeur qui
va faire un élève arriver au meilleur de
son potentiel
voilà maître de chai c'est un tout c'est
quelqu'un qui va fédérer ses équipes
puisqu'il n'est pas tout seul et à le
préparateur il ya d'autres personnes qui
vont l'aider à faire ses assemblages